[Music]
foreign
as long as you're you how did you figure
it out because I've always wondered that
because you you figured it out and there
was like a big turnaround like one day
you just stopped giving a [__]
was weird it was a a it was a a an event
it was a series of events
it was that I wasn't
dating that dirty you got a lighter over
there
I wasn't dating that dirty [__] anymore
that clears your mind at 30 percent
I had let go a lot of [__] that was
[__] scaring the [__] out of me in LA
and that's 60 of your problem right
there everybody had me locked in
bullshitting me that you needed to do
this and needed to do that
and you you know and all of a sudden I'm
watching you and I'm watching these guys
the the clean
but they make me laugh but they're not
making me laugh like the guys that are
real yeah that took a different [__]
animal you know I remember I was having
conversations about it yeah when you
were like ah you could go do that I
gotta I gotta you know there's people
watching me yeah no no it was scary it
was scary for no reason yeah it was just
the [__] that they put into your
head that you can't and you can't well
it was no reason but it was holding you
back absolutely because people could see
when you're faking the funk well not
just that like even once you started
killing it was still holding you back
like there was still a lot of agents and
managers who had a bad opinion of you oh
listen they're gonna
they're gonna say whatever you want to
say but until you deliver the goods
that's exactly I figured out I was
talking to Tommy Easter today
and I go Tommy Easter let me tell you
something you could be the funniest guy
in this town you going to come you start
every night
and [__] destroy that room even
though they're going to see Dane Cook
Eliza Schlesinger it doesn't matter you
can destroy that room nothing matters in
this business just like the Mafia These
the size of the envelope on Friday
that's when they pay attention to you
that's when all those naysayers they eat
their words
and they jump on the ship with you well
what's interesting is those people are
are almost useless now useless young
comic it's it's it's this has changed
yeah this has changed and let me tell
you something I know you hate this talk
but this is the reality because you're
an intelligent guy in 2007 there was a
writer strike and these [__]
play a game for six or seven months and
reality TV crept it there's about to be
another Rider strike May 7th this is and
if these [__] play games
the internet
is gonna [__] them up well where it's
not gonna [__] them up as things like
Game of Thrones or things like House of
Cards like things where you need a lot
of money to shoot them well listen let
me tell you something when the going
gets rough you put together one of these
late night shows with Brendan and Eddie
lighting himself on fire or whatever
from 8 to 11 put a band behind you
people are gonna watch it dog the
internet's gonna change the [__] game
if these [__] [__] around on TV
if these [__] don't settle this
and this goes on like the one in 2007.
you think Periscope didn't see this
coming in all these [__] companies
didn't see this coming yeah but don't
you think the writers probably have a
point like all the writers always have a
point no they're without them there's
nothing right right writers always have
a point
but listen it's 2017 [__] he will
hesitate masturbate this [__] machine
over here has been growing since you
turned me on to it it's nothing but a
wealth of information and growth that
machine and more people turn to that you
know I don't I don't do this I don't do
this because I'm an idiot but people
watch movies on their phones yeah
okay my boyfriend yeah don't watch
anything of that content is endless now
content is endless you don't need cable
or TV no more you got a phone if you're
broke if you're a brokster and you got
an iPhone
and you're trying to work things out in
your life you don't need you can stream
Showtime you can stream HBO you could
stream IFC and you can see almost
everything everything YouTube just came
out with a uh like everyone's coming out
with an online cable service or TV
service but YouTube's is is the best one
out there for so far it's 30 bucks a
month and you get you get I don't you
don't get every channel but you get a
ton of eight you get a ton of DVR so
it's starting to be where you don't even
need anything let them [__] around keep
[__] around
keep it up he's going to figure this out
and go wait a second I got a good idea
for this I got a good idea for that two
cameras two GoPros and periscope
and a drummer and you got yourself
entertainment Jack for whoever people
watch it people at home craving this our
audience is not from seven to ten no
more like it was 20 years ago sorry it's
people from seven to five it's I.T
people it's people working gas stations
just people working construction with
earphones on It's [__] amazing the
the loaders at the airport planes they
waved the other
I'm trying to get on the [__] plane
they waved a couple weeks ago yeah it's
weird right it's very weird so it's gone
to a different [__] level now
this is what we're doing is growing
every month well no one would ever allow
you to do this no this is not no there's
no there's no executive in this town
that would have ever said here's what
you need to do Joey no they wouldn't
have a camera pointed at you you start
smoking pot and just talk [__] nobody
believed you nobody would believe you
and it's that easy it's that [__]
easy it is for you no it's not that easy
for everybody well they listen man but
it's a shot you have a shot with this
when Marin first went to his management
and said he was starting to pack as they
laughed at him yeah that's the reality
of it you know yeah this is something
that they didn't know it was coming yeah
they're going they're sitting having
meetings right now what are we gonna do
how are we going to get a piece of
design well I know that some podcasts
are saying you know that right they have
those acting podcasts really
how do they do that
we read a play no [__] yeah they have
series oh well series is huge huge I I
firmly believe that the future of
entertainment is audio I honestly do
because
it gives you so much more uh X you're so
much more accessible to them like that
you can you have them for the drive you
have them throughout the work day and
then even at home
how many people do you see when they're
watching TV just playing on their phone
throughout the entire episode and they
they're absorbing what's happening
through audio I honestly think there's
going to be a lot I've always loved
audio oh it's it's perfect I think
people don't listen enough I love all
you I grew up on Richard Pryor albums
we grew up listening we have specials I
grew up listening to George Carlin I
grew up listening to I didn't watch
[__] Freddie Prince on TV with a
special how many specials did we see
later on Delirious Rodney's young
comedians but that came later on
well there's definitely a good market
for audio but there's always going to be
a market for people watching things too
and if you're talking about people that
are sitting down with their phones while
they're watching a TV show like that's
so silly people that do that are so
silly you're playing with your phone
while you're watching The Walking Dead
or something like that it's so dumb I
think they're I I hate it okay it's just
people who are super super distracted
and childish with the way they look at
things if you're doing that unless it's
a bad show or unless you like watching a
talk show or something like that but it
just seems to me that like if you're
gonna watch a really good show you
should put the [__] phone down and
sit down and watch that thing this is
[__] that was [__] tremendous that
was my first Led Zeppelin now that's the
first one I ever had that took me to a
tremendous level and I would listen to
houses of the Holy I would listen to
dancing days and I was so young that I
was scared of uh no quarter so I would
skip over it and go to the ocean you got
to be a certain age listen to the
recorder you ain't ready for that yeah I
found about Led Zeppelin from this girl
that lived up the street from me when I
was 13. there was a girl that lived up
the street that [__] everybody she was
21 and I was 13 and she fooled around me
but I couldn't get it up I was too young
but she played comfortably numb the
first time I ever kissed a check I
kissed a 21 year old chick when I was 13
and she's grabbing my dick but nothing
was going on I was panicking but that
song Comfortably Numb will always be
associated in my mind with that girl and
and uh and black dog that was the first
time I ever heard black dog was his
chick she turned me on the Zeppelin turn
me on a lot of good music man that's
amazing when they take and you go home
and go what the [__] was that I was
listening to oh I had no idea because
the only music I had heard when I was 13
was probably a new kiss I knew about
kiss I was a kiss fan already but I
didn't know about that many bands it was
hard you had to listen to the radio you
know you didn't it was you couldn't like
I didn't have friends who like turned me
on to Too Much music it was like it was
hard to find out about good stuff so
when I first found out about Zeppelin
like how the [__] did I not know about
this so I got my car today this morning
at eight in the morning and Philadelphia
Freedom was on by Elton John and I
started singing it and my wife is
looking like when the [__] did you learn
these lyrics I go Doug oh this is sixth
grade on Fridays Mr levito will let me
go up in front of the class at one
o'clock and I was saying Philadelphia
Freedom my lip sync it
and my eyes adored you by Frankie Valli
and [__] I should take [__]
deep with the with with the [__]
Elton John people don't remember Elton
John every once in a while I get caught
up with something John I can't even go
in the house country Comfort uh Funeral
For A Friend last week something was on
Daniel my friend and like and there's
two gay guys live across the street from
me but they're the [__] weirdest gay
guys because they don't go out they
don't do nothing they sit in that
[__] house all day I want to kick
that door down and go you know anybody
tell you you're [__] gay get out
there dick is free
sperm is free you go to Santa Monica you
know that dick is free free these two
gay guys stay in the [__] and they're
not gay together what they're not
together
for the roommates yeah they're roommates
and they never [__] go out every once
in a while in the daytime they take a
cruise they're in front of the house
feeding cats
so when the other day I got out of the
car I was listening to Elton John and I
was blasting I was stoned you know and
the weed and the music just connect is
one I pulled up to the house and they
were like out there and I opened up the
window and I go nobody in this country
remembers when Elton John used to sling
dick like a [__] and they just
looked at me looked at each other one in
the house
nobody in this country nobody gave a
[__] he was gay like you had an idea him
and Bernie Talking were gay but you yeah
he could be but who gives a [__] dog
Street Fighting Man yeah whatever all
that [__] was just brilliant you know
every anybody that that song it's a
little bit sunny or funny you know that
[__] everybody knows that [__] Jam
you broke up to that you gave a girl
your first hickey you fingered somebody
for that there's always some Rocket Man
rocking man too what's the one in and uh
what's the movie about the young kid who
was the writer and they all got on the
Tiny Dancer what is it and they all was
singing it on the [__] bus and you
were feeling it you're like God damn how
good of a [__] song is that when a
band wouldn't that supposed to be who
that's supposed to be theoretically and
Almost Famous wasn't that supposed to be
Led Zeppelin to somebody big time that
they were writing about when they were
on the bus I thought it was Morrison
wasn't it supposed to be sure
I don't think it was the doors well
although speaking Last Friday Night
[__] The Doors Live at the Hollywood
Bowl was on if you haven't seen that
smoke a number get some [__] Juju
juice whatever the [__] you're just
smoking a number these e-cigars I never
even heard of anything yeah these are
[__] good yeah yeah this tastes like
a cigar it's amazing and they have
different levels of nicotine because I'm
not a smoker so I got zero just to try
it out it tastes the same okay it's
great this is great I love this game
I go to Vegas I don't feel like an
[__] no more now you go to a casino
you don't feel like an [__] no more
it's discreet you know whatever at least
it saves you you know you don't wanna
you know why I hate getting cigars
because I spend three dollars on a cigar
and I smoke half of it you know what I'm
gonna do putting a baggie in my pocket
like a Puerto Rican and walk around it
always tastes like [__] yeah no I can't
so when do you have time to actually sit
there for four [__] hours you get a
little one get a smaller one well on the
East Coast they have Cigar loungers or
like whether have like nice leather
furniture and you can get a drink that's
really fun they have one right next to
the Improv do they really yeah they've
had that one they've had that yes Kevin
James and I used to go to fat stogies in
Studio City across the street from
Jerry's Deli oh I didn't know they had
them they were so much fun God damn it
what God damn it I got something for you
I didn't print it up my friend sent me a
poster a picture that's really a post
he's gonna give it to me in New York of
the number one pool hall in Cuba in 1951
like when it was booming dog 200
[__] in there wow dressed
impeccably like impeccably like no jeans
like suits on women with minks on little
things of champagne on buckets and these
[__] are shooting pool and you
can see like the daylight come over the
beach and [__] God damn Cuba 19 [__]
51. isn't it crazy how Cuba used to be
like the this was the place this was the
place they all would go there Kennedy
would go there the mob would go there
everybody went to Cuba you know actors
ambassadors it was everybody's place to
go how long of a plane ride would be for
Miami like 20 minutes like how long
could it possibly be 40 minutes or
something it's not even 90 miles so it's
from here to San Diego yeah that's like
not even half the trip to Vegas they
have to do a circle just to feel yeah
just to make it worth it you know listen
some United has blown for years I took
him into Newark one time no [__] TV
no [__] shitty food
first class was like [__] garbage
into North that's why I don't I don't
fly into Newark no more you know uh I
love whatever virgin but then it can't
get me back from Newark so I'm gonna end
up at Kennedy anyway yeah
so no New York's not a good airport no I
don't used to [__] about it I already
used to [__] about it constantly
[__] Newark [__] Newark you know what
my life's a lot easier believe it or not
when I land in JFK yeah it really is
smooth worst case scenario you go to
[__] The Palms and get a steak and
eggs yeah like a gentleman and a bloody
Mary and you set it up there's tons of
entertainment activity oh yeah you get a
massage and get your feet rubbed they
got [__] in everything at Kennedy
I thought you flew out okay
it was horrible
it was horrible and I'm like you I
waited 10 minutes I had already a book
three o'clock but it got in at 7 41 and
I didn't trust it yeah I went to
Southwest was empty everybody was there
when I got there was kids at the airport
all going to [__] uh spring break
I went to United they had nothing I went
to Delta Delta was done
and I went to the other one
JetBlue and JetBlue was done until
tomorrow until Sunday
I was like you know what I got my 340 I
take my chances yeah before I left the
hotel I called and they go to the plane
that you're going from ballet is already
in Chicago he landed from Rome this
morning it's already ready to go it's on
time
and the other one was on time and you
know what everything was smooth knock on
wood took me 25 minutes up to 405 to get
a whole month and it was empty yeah you
have options in other places but if you
fly to a place like Buffalo there's not
a lot of options you know it's like if
you're flying out of Bozeman Montana or
something like that like good luck
listen bro I can't get a direct ticket
from Milwaukee to Detroit
the flight the flight is longer from
Milwaukee to Detroit than what it is
from [__] LAX to [__] Milwaukee
really how the [__] could that happen
I gotta fly into Chicago it's a tough
business the business of uh selling
airline tickets and flying people around
yeah you got to make money not really
well you got to think who the [__] is
flying in and out of Buffalo so in order
for them to have packed like what's
there right other than the UFC like when
you have a big event or a football game
or something like that if there's not
that a lot of people connect to go to
Canada a lot of people fly to Buffalo
those planes are always pretty [__]
airport was empty my at three o'clock
the airport was completely empty when I
walked in everybody flew out earlier and
I'll tell you what when I landed at LAX
empty LAX was empty empty I couldn't
[__] believe it I've never seen it
like if I was like wait a second no one
could get back in have you do you guys
ever have you guys boycotted an airline
because like it's weird you can't they
have you over a barrel you can get as
mad as you wanted them but some Airlines
only fly certain places and they're the
cheaper ones so you gotta find them
sometimes I bet a lot of people gonna
boycott United after that
yeah but until the next vacation like
not many be like you guys fly a lot more
than most people fly yeah I think what
most people find it's just whatever
airline's cheapest yeah but if people
have an option now I think they're gonna
choose my first choice is always
American I know where I'm going yeah I
know where I'm going if I go to New York
I'm only going Delta or the other one
America sinks your boat and the virgin's
great but they're going away virgin's
not going to be around anymore where are
they going they're merging with somebody
Alaska broke somewhere that like I don't
know why I took I took Alaska Airlines
that was the only direct flight into
Baltimore
was Alaska a [__] Airlines a red eye
they do all right Alaska does all right
and they fly me to Portland from Burbank
yeah they're good to Seattle too really
yeah yeah no no no tremendous not bad
so that's the end of the Virgin I'm
telling you I'm telling you the leader
right now is that mint and I know you I
know this type of guy you are yeah I
know the type of guy you are they got a
door they got to do the in the and
there's a latch right here that closes
your door so you go the door goes like a
Batman movie it just closes real fast
when they bring you the food they press
the latch and the door opens and that's
how she gives you the food like prisoner
44.
I don't even know what you're saying I
don't even know what it looks like I put
the sleep apnea machine right here I
think it's like a pod like those
Internationals let's see if you can find
that jet blue Jack blue I like Delta to
Kennedy it's very nice very nice they
got the lay down bed and [__] I'm
getting real tired of flying I know I
would like to do a residency in Los
Angeles
everybody goes to Vegas to do a
residency how many [__] people are
there in L.A you could sell on La every
weekend if you had a club like just a
club Playa Del Carmen down there where's
that blood down there right by the
airport where's Playa Del Carmen by our
friend that's where he has the his uh
Brendan has the office down there nice
and clean down there Joe Rogan that's a
good spot but anywhere down by the ocean
takes forever to drive that's what it
looks like the Pod let me let me see
this thing let me see a close-up dude
that's nice that's JetBlue yeah I'm dog
is this a new thing yeah how many of
these they have they have uh you can
only go from here to Boston or here
to uh JK JFK so the whole point is
filled with these things no the front
row it's like eight rows but you get a
an even number and you're by yourself in
the case so it's like essentially like
first class
so they're doing first class there you
go that's by yourself that's by yourself
they see that little box they give you
they give you a thing to cover your eyes
they give you a blanket they give you a
pillow the bottled water is behind your
left arm can't even [__] see it you
know I'm almost not and it's got a
statue you can put your bottled water
right in there you got movies I Saw The
Godfather Two on the way there
that's the refrigerator and the cheap
seats yeah the refrigerator yeah you
just get up and help your [__] self
this is for everybody yeah this is where
everybody is
that's so mid-flight you don't have to
bother nobody you get up you get your
[__] soda these people are getting
it's 2017. wow but those front rows I'm
telling your dog tremendous I was blown
the [__] away that's just like first
class and that goes to Kennedy goes to
Kennedy but not from Burbank me and
Bob's rooting out of this conversation
because Marsh was like you got to get on
mint I go ah Burbank there's no mint
because it's a small airport right so
the bigger plane can't land on there oh
is that what it is
oh that makes sense
that makes sense I always wondered
whether they don't land in Newark either
nothing out of Burbank does two small
flights probably small flights no
JetBlue doesn't fly into [__] Newark
oh uh well you don't want to fly into
New York even if I landed even if I work
in New Jersey I usually don't fly in
Newark I fly in New York I've been flew
into Atlantic City
yes when I did the UFC there I did from
right from here I think I don't remember
it was so long I got it so long ago I
did the Borgata do you do the Borgata
with me yes it was fine with military
it's one of the few places like the
borgat is one of the few places and uh
henzo Gracie showed up too remember yeah
he was howling at your [__] that's right
they were crazy I remember henzo Gracie
is a [__] Maniac he thought oh he was
like the dirtier the crazier you got the
more he was like
it was [__] [__] flopping around in
his seat laughing
I always walk past that place I'm scared
to walk it Enzo's yeah in New York
there's a killers they are killers but
they're super nice guys it's a horror
she'll get tapped out but they'll be
nice to you oh my God that's just how it
goes yeah I'm scared of those New York
schools I always make plans yeah I'm
gonna go over there after Norton Show
and show up yeah [__] you he's a great
guy though I get in that goddamn ooh but
I shoot right back for that fairy Jack
yeah and I don't look back [__] you
they'll kill you became an hour 10 plus
they doubled the price
this time's the plane in Vegas has been
50 minutes behind and they still got me
here on time
from Vegas to Burbank they know it's not
that [__] do you think you really
think they take a secure this route
really let me kill someone why would
they do that because how guilty would
you feel if you took somebody for a half
hour from here to Vegas it's not a guilt
2013 the fuel the fuel costs so much
money they'd be crazy to do that
I don't know don't yeah it'd be crazy to
do that I think fuel is the number one
problem with air travel the reason why
they have to Jack the rates up all the
time is jet fuel keeps getting more and
more expensive are you serious as car
fuel gets more expensive jet fuel gets
more defensive car fuel is not that bad
right now it's not that bad right now
but do you remember when Bush was
leaving office yes Ron White started
flying commercial and that's when he got
busted with weed because his [__]
[__] ex-wife I don't know her maybe
she's an isolated I'm just on Ron's side
but uh she she ratted him out and said
he was going to be at the airport with
weed in his pocket so the cops met him
uh at the airport with his luggage and
busted him they want to sting for a
little bit of weed yep I'm staying for a
little bit of weed you could Google it
he he went to [__] I mean I don't
know if he got arrested went to jail but
he definitely got popped at the airport
and it's because he was always flying
private because he was doing the [__]
Blue Collar tour just bawling out of
control did you know Bill Murray got
arrested for weed I read that today
because I was reading something about
him and his relationship with uh the guy
who just died he got arrested with like
bales of weed Bales but it was it was a
lot I'm gonna have to look it up I read
an article today about like the
relationship and he he wasn't making he
wasn't paying rent and him and his
brother had like 17 something crazy like
huge amount of weed let me look it up
you know he took a long time off of
movies and Bill Murray's got a brother
who's a priest like a big time [__]
priest somewhere like I've heard this a
couple [__] times
yeah yeah wow yeah he was arrested with
10 pounds
what year let's see 1970. whoa that's
when 10 pounds was really ten pounds and
that's before acting that's pre-acting
yeah amazing yeah he got yeah was it was
that before Saturday Night Live yes I
know I was 73 74 75. he only got
probation he got five years probation
yeah Wow first time a Fan's ten pounds
10 pounds a lot of [__] I'm addicted
I can't stop smoking marijuana I can't
stop smoking marijuana and eating white
chicks can you tell the stories about
bringing guns back from Colorado to New
York every other weekend you know Bill
Murray is the real deal man when he
played uh
the guy first Gonzo he played the yeah
right at first and uh where the Buffalo
Where the Buffalo roams he really you
know that's why I saw him I saw him in
[__] Woody Creek timing and he was
sitting with the dude he's preparing for
it yeah like he did a [__] great
[__] job in that movie people sleep
on that nobody ever saw it nobody even
knows that movie exists I have that
movie you have it at home I'm a huge
Honduras Thompson fan yeah that is when
he answers the phone when he's arguing
with the dude or he's talking to him
real mildly and he just answer the phone
he goes what yeah I lose it every time I
know where I saw that movie the first
time you know where were we with the
internet what were we watching the other
night that people were going Blues
Brothers
we were in the brand improv watching
Blues Brothers Mayhem Matt Voltron
losing it the scene at the bar at the
bar losing at that when he play when
they play and they get hit with the
bottles and they do uh Stand By Your Man
[__] Belushi was just on a different
level oh yeah and I don't know if you
know do you say it's the drugs I'll tell
you when you do that many drugs and you
wake up the next morning the next day
you're very unconscious
best days I had as a Salesman when
nights I [__] and I felt my spine
tingling you know what I'm saying when
nights that I [__] felt the electric
jolt of cocaine I would be a sports
salesman and I would wake up and go in
and by 12 o'clock on May 3 Grand is it
like a hangover what is it like it
wasn't it was a hangover but I'm
unconscious I really don't know what I'm
doing
you know when you think about things and
you go into something and you think
about it you can't really it's when you
don't think about it that's when you're
just flowing and I was just flowing it I
would say Joey no nerves what is it on
Saturdays you always do great and I
remember I used to smell so much coat
then that I couldn't even get sprays to
open up my nose so I would take two
tissues and just stick them up my nose
so the drain and I would sit there all
day with two tissues they would look at
me and go what's up nothing at the car
dealership no no Sports deals no sports
betting so I'd be on the phones talking
but even with cars my best days were
after a 10 hour [__] benjathon you
know
wow it's [__] amazing yes last night
I was telling you guys I went to the
Dodger game my uncle now this is the
same uncle that we pulled guns on each
other 25 years ago this week is the 30th
anniversary of you guys pulling guns
guns on each other at night September of
84 on Vermont Boulevard here really down
here yeah right my uncle my mother's
Brother Blood not like oh we're brothers
no blood grew up together cubed in the
same house lives in Glendale always has
since I used to come out here when I was
a kid that's what I'm like I used to
come out here when I was a kid
I don't know who's [__] buzzing that
is it's not mine I don't have one of
those dings when I first came out here
uh
when I first
when I first came out here I came out
here when I was eight nine and ten and
we go to Dodger games Sea World Malibu
we go to his different jobs
I know my mother died I could have came
back with him but I was like California
what the [__] am I know about California
I kept in touch with him and then when I
was 21 I said [__] New York
people were looking for me I gotta get
out of town so I came out here and I
tried to make give this a go you know
and he wasn't going for a job he was
like you got a room upstairs you got a
week to get your [__] together if you
don't get it together in a week you got
to go dog and I was like you're my
mother's brother but he threw me out and
I couldn't take it so I tried to Rob him
ha I couldn't go home with nothing so I
pulled guns we pulled guns the cops came
the cab came because I was robbing them
as he pulled up and he called the cops
and the cab team
so I swore to God I go next time I see
I'm gonna [__] shoot you you
[__] I mean this was terrible
this was horrendous didn't you call him
from prison was it him oh I used to call
him from prison and tell him they want
my dolly who had put I used to tell him
I'm gonna [__] call him
I know what this is I'm gonna come after
you and I would hang up on him I was
pissed I was pissed now you're going to
Dodger games with him yeah man it's uh
we had him on the podcast we had him on
the podcast do you think you could ever
live in Manhattan
we had this discussion with uh somebody
a few weeks ago and they showed the rent
of where I grew up on 88th Street and I
nearly Strip My Pants oh it's insane the
same place where I grew up now I think
it was what was it seven grand for a one
bedroom
that's not even outrageous yeah
the the the money there so crazy it
makes you wonder how anyone can afford
to live there other than like really
wealthy people
if there's any City that gives me
anxiety it's New York City at night
anymore yeah I've gotten to the age that
I've gotten very comfortable here and
when I go play the stand on Thursday
nights I stand on the corner before you
go in
and I actually [__] can't take the
cars anymore like the speed that that
electricity I'm not used to it anymore
really yeah it [__] with me a little
bit so on Thursdays I don't go into the
city no more I wait till I go to the
shows and I you know it's weird how you
when you're from that area it takes you
a couple days to acclimate like I was
getting on the ferry and I was getting
bullied
on the ferry you yeah getting bullied
straight up people walk in front of me
and [__] but I'm from L.A I don't need
this aggravation I'm so dirty these days
they were doing that oh they're [__]
rude [__] the people who live
on the Jersey side and they work in New
York they think they [__] don't stink so
they cut you off you know and you
overcome it because you're an adult and
you don't give a [__]
by Saturday some lady pregnant with a
[__] thing was trying to cut me off
and I finally go oh relax like you
forget that you're a nice person like
you forget wow people not opening up
doors like people pushing you know like
you know what I'm from a different
civilization you know like people you
forget and then you toughen up by
Saturday but then you'll leave on Sunday
anyway so what's the toughness for you
know what I've been saying for a while
is that what's going on in New York and
what goes on the entire East Coast with
the difference between the way people uh
behave there versus out here is that
they're still too close to the people
that first landed there like the people
that first landed there like my
grandparents and their families they
came up they came over from Europe Italy
and Ireland and everything like that
those were barbarians those people were
animals I mean you just think about life
like you're talking about the depression
right this is all uh my grandparents
came like when the Depression was going
on they I mean it was a hard hard world
people were tough and they were mean and
you got [__] with and you know my
grandfather used to tell me horror
stories about getting bullied and they
call them a guinea [__] like and just
mean [__] and beating them up and just
everybody was mean
yeah yeah that's how you have to look at
the heart of the Indian world if it was
today Trump would ban [__] travel to
Italy yeah probably though no I saw that
documentary and it was the most
interesting thing I ever saw
really taught me a lot about that
culture I grew up around because it
always seemed very interesting to me HBO
did a two-part special on Sinatra and
the first part they discussed his
childhood and Hoboken and how at that
time the Irish were the oppress it
depressor the oppressor so the guineas
weren't allowed past 9th Street really
which really [__] with them
then stuff happened and the Italians you
know grew and then they got past 9th
Street but so nacho always had that
mentality
of I was never allowed over 9th Street
you gotta watch it it's [__]
interesting plus I understood the people
I grew up with from North American see
Hoboken is moving on up to North Bergen
we're gonna get a house up in North
Bergen we got a front yard you know what
I'm saying like half of the people I
grew up with the roots are Hoboken
so when I watched that special so North
Bergen was better North Bergen was more
residential the way Hoboken was more you
know tournaments and three floors and
you know yeah North Bergen once they
built North Bergen a lot of people moved
to North Bergen there used to be a club
there used to be a club in Hoboken what
was it it was a stand-up Club there
I do not remember I was long gone by
they still do stand up there Danny
Aiello has a room on Tuesday nights
uh they've been really trying like over
the years to do stand-ups I did a
benefit from the Hoboken Police
Department oh yeah oh a long time ago I
did it I did the club there in like 91
or 92 or something like that and they
had pictures all over the wall the time
Eddie Murphy stopped by and so I
remember like Eddie Murphy was here at
one point in time like you know they had
like a photo and it said you know like
1989 Eddie Murphy you know it was like
three years ago and everybody's like oh
remember that time three years ago Eddie
Murphy came down there [__] I didn't
know it was a comedy club in Hoboken
when I started I started in Denver when
I went back the big Club was Rascals and
the other one but there was also Main
Street showcase
hmm it was I I it was always it was
I saw Bill Bellamy on the plane one time
and I was talking to him about it uh he
goes yeah that was my roots Main Street
showcase Bill Bellamy I forgot about it
Jane Moore all those guys were from that
part of New Jersey and when Florentine
came in here him and Norton are from
like South Jersey middle New Jersey and
they moved to Northern New Jersey got an
apartment
and they were all Jersey guys
at their Jersey guys I'm saying don't
take them seriously yeah right but he
was saying that nobody took them
seriously yeah Norton always had that it
like bothered him he's not funny till
you moved to New York yeah isn't that
funny like you have to go to New York to
be taken seriously if you live in New
Jersey or just a hack
telling fart jokes and [__] you know
those clubs in Jersey are brutal
I mean bananas is is
brutal and it's brutal you do come in a
ping pong table one in Poughkeepsie I
did the one in Poughkeepsie I did that
one a couple times that's in a ballroom
way yeah and the next it's next to a gas
station that's as good as it gets dog
and they put you in the downstairs room
and when I tell you it's [__]
freezing it's [__] freezing they got
one Diner in the lobby and it's the
worst Food you've ever eaten your life
even if they give you the 30 off you'd
rather [__] started that that's how
bad that place is and you're stuck up
there for two [__] nights
next to a gas station
that's it I worked up there with Tony V
do you know Tony V [__] yeah I worked up
there with Tony B I was the middle he
was the headliner and some lady kept
flashing the light while I was on stage
I was supposed to do like I don't know
20 25 minutes something like that I had
like 10 or 15 she's flashing on it uh
and I did I ignored it I just did my set
I got off stage and she goes okay I
don't know if you know how we do it here
but you can't do that language at this
club
and I remember saying like what are you
talking about like I was I was I was
laughing because I I was already moved
to New York I was already like I was
already getting work I already had sauce
when I was a manager I was like what and
she was like you're gonna have to change
your act work oh no I'm not like what
are you the manager here like I got
booked here I got booked here by the
owner of the club I go I'm gonna do my
ACT they know what my ACT is I mean you
don't like it so you want me to change
and like she looked at me and you know
like she didn't expect that
and I just raised my eyebrows and I just
walked away and I just finished out the
weekend and she never spoke a [__]
word to me again she didn't say hi she
didn't look at me that great when you
have the [__] one side yeah you gotta
drop a bomb on a [__] and she'll
just look at you like what she was
talking to me like she was the manager
at Wendy's and I was the Fry Boy she's
like I don't know if you know how this
works here you know like she's like the
lady that takes the tickets you know how
those the clubs are all in a hotel you
know like bananas was in a hotel right
yeah both of them both of them so she
just decided she didn't like my act you
know because I talked about sex so she's
just decided that I was gonna have to
change my act I don't know I'll just
I'll never forget her face I don't know
if you know how we do it here but you're
you can't do with that language here
it's amazing those people it looks like
an apple he has to go to Huntington
Beach to buy him he brought walnuts
organic walnuts and something else
for the last 50 years he doesn't eat
like a Cuban person he eats like a
[__] Gentile from Studio City but he
goes nuts like organic milk because
whole milk makes you swell up you give
him flame I mean he didn't stop every
time I see him it's a [__] hip
beating he brings his own eggs to a
diner and makes them cook them yeah he
don't like regular eggs like you he
don't he don't believe in eggs from his
store you know you're very different
he's got to [__] get his own eggs or
they got to eat organic grass I should
have brought you over some eggs oh I
could just know how delicious uh real
[__] eggs I get almost a dozen eggs a
day a day yeah 24 chickens and how great
are these oh they're tremendous they
look different they're the the oh the
yolk is like a dark orange and they
taste different they taste better I mean
I get them fresh fresh like I'm eating
eggs that just came out of the chicken
that day
how long I never understood how chickens
do they have to have sex because
sometimes it like sex or they just keep
laying eggs no they lay eggs every day
if the hen [__] them the eggs are live
then the eggs become a chick but if the
if the the rooster if the rooster
doesn't [__] them then they just lay
eggs I don't have any roosters so the
hens just they lay eggs they're just
Duds they lay them every day all those
are duds yeah they're Duds oh wow they
could never become a person a person
never could become a chicken I didn't
know that either until I got chicken
yeah I never because they I knew they
did it every day but I was like why it's
crazy that vegans won't eat chicken eggs
like they cannot become a chicken it's
impossible and look if you go by my
house my chickens are like my friends
like they come and hang out like Jessica
loves them their chickens are the the
kids love them they're they're [__]
they're little animals man like
they're hanging around the yard
oh you can pick them up yeah you pick
them up and everything
oh my God they're beautiful yeah I got
24 of them and you have a little place
for them and everything oh yeah they
have a big house they have a chicken
house I had it built they go wandering
around my yard
and then the night they go back in they
go back in on their own no no drama from
the animals there's been no not for my
dogs no but there's been coyote drama
and Hawk drama the Hawks see them and
the Hawks are trying to get in on them
but the area where they're at there's a
lot of trees and they go into the trees
and so the Hawks have to have an area to
swoop in grab them and then swoop back
out and they're a little too big for
that so now but when they were little
there was one of them turned up missing
I'm pretty sure Hawk got one of them one
of the smaller ones it was a long ass
time ago but the coyotes coyotes go
around the fence and they look in every
now and I catch them looking in I'm
gonna get a [__] pistol and air
pistol I think
set them up set them up amazing put a
little cat food out there
pink
no my uncle makes everybody hands down
look bad like you drove major yeah it's
amazing no rice no no nothing
just eats real healthy uh he's been
juicing for 50 years he's like these
[__] Jack offs they think they
invented something me and Jacqueline had
a talk 50 years ago and he told me about
juicing did he really ever talk to Jack
away Jacqueline was he was the guy that
was doing that a long time ago he would
take like a [__] giant bowl of
vegetables and juicing it down juicing
down so my uncle said when he came out
here in 50 something he came out here to
be somebody's maintenance man
he was working in New York as a
maintenance man of building and an actor
lived in the building that was a soap
opera guy and he goes I got a big house
in L.A could you come out there and be a
maintenance man there's a house there in
the back feet you could live back there
well it's like [__] I don't live in New
York anyway they came out here then the
guy had some TV show so my uncle would
go down to the studio and he said he
meant that he was like in Spanish it's
really funny he was telling her he was
an esmerized with Jacqueline this guy
used to do push-ups with one [__]
hand you know like the Cubans that's
huge he was a [__] Savage and he
always said then that you always should
eat a carrot Blended or something yeah
my uncle said what an onions I mean I
heard Jacqueline used to go [__] garlic
yeah garlic it's a shame and he yeah he
was the original juicer so he's been
juicing he juices he only has a a
certain he hasn't eaten sugar in 50
years the word is a Jacqueline would
[__] everything that move female or male
male oh not a female
you know when I was a kid I remember
waking up and that [__] had an
exercise show at 9am with the suit oh
yeah he had the suit so you never know I
had a jumpsuit that little [__]
jumpsuit no no he would uh you know he
would uh
he was eating healthy before everybody
he was working out like deep into his
60s and 70s he was doing stunts or like
for his 60th birthday he towed like 60
boats behind him like swimming he did a
bunch of really crazy [__] like that
like he was in incredible Fitness
incredible shape but yet [__]
everything you couldn't go near him even
when he was older
he was all there I mean which makes
sense I mean why would he be so
motivated to have such a great body like
deep into his 50s and 60s
you know you're [__] horny as [__]
yeah he's flying when you throw a metal
around and [__] push-ups and pull-ups
jumping you guys dick for three or four
people you really do you you really do
when you lift weights and [__] like when
I was going at uh kettlebell gym I
really like the [__] deadlifts and
[__] I had dick for days like I could
jerk off give somebody a stabbing and I
do have to bang one out again standing
up that's the worst you gotta bang one
out standing up in your bathroom hiding
against the doors
yeah there's something pathetic about
jerking off standing up I haven't done
that a lot oh that's a disgusting way
when you have to bang one out in the
shower and then you're late I like
hotels because you lay down on your back
it just comes on you like a fountain you
don't give a [__] it's your own come my
married friend since he has to do it
into the toilet like he does it on his
iPhone in his bathroom because his
girlfriend oh my God he should be shot
oh God that's sad I would never just
shoot into a twirl you gotta play with
it well see the thing is too about like
when you're away like if you go away
like if you do like a comedy or
something like that where you go on the
road you come back home and you know you
miss your girlfriend you miss your wife
you you're looking forward to seeing her
again but when you're with someone all
the time and you can't even jerk off
because like you're at work all day you
can't jerk off at work you get home
she's home you're there together every
night day in day out the monotony and
the grind and then you're jerking off
into a toilet that there's just
something just defeating about it takes
all the the zest out of life you're just
hiding in the bathroom why are you in
there for so long what are you doing I
don't like that I like working let me I
have to get a Q-tip
what do you why is the door locked what
are you doing
you've been in there for five minutes
what are you doing
yeah
just trade
jerking off down downward jerking
because you just you don't want to miss
the toilet you don't want to shoot all
over the top you don't want to Upper
Deck your load I don't think I don't
think that's accurate about that I've
jerked off everywhere I have found a
whale like this time you're sitting
there you're like you know what I got 10
minutes
by the way you never whacked off when
you're on the trailer Fear Factor oh I
walked up [__] yeah you just you never
wanked off when you were editing and
then office no
you're by yourself you have a whack off
driving [__] yeah I'm not not fully but
I've like gotten horned up but I've
never I can't imagine coming on like
that oh I [__] have you really yeah
[__] yeah you look for an old
McDonald's bag you wipe that [__]
sperm on it I get nervous when I sneeze
when I'm driving
in three [__] days I only whacked off
once while driving and I I remember
after I jerked off while I was driving I
was like great now I jerk off in the car
too I was thinking I was gonna do this
all the time and I for whatever reason I
only did it once one [__] I think I did
it one time when I was driving limos I
just lifted up my shirt shot one all
over my stomach put the shirt down
patted it down
coming back from New Hampshire I did the
week one time I was dumb enough to take
a week because I was a Coke that [__]
Savage at the Houston little Club the
little Club the little Club on the south
side oh that's the one that Ralphie used
to do yes yeah so they put you up in a
hotel in the middle of nowhere right
it's like it's out there okay that
somebody else took it over now they sold
it and somebody else took it over that
club was there for a long time
they got a different type of audience
than West Gray let's just say it was
completely different than the last stop
I went there one Sunday night and the
owner was there and I did my set and he
goes when do you want to get booked here
and I go you know I called Pete I go pee
you money goes no no take the week I
took the Thursday Friday and Saturday so
I get the heat I do the Thursday night
he's not there the wife is there
so the same thing [__] happened right
before I go on stage and at that time I
wasn't my head wasn't in it like that
she came up to me she's like listen
I heard rumors not here here we work
spotless clean if you say one bad thing
you're fired
oh those [__] people well guess what
I [__] my pants I really did it for the
first 15 I tried I struggled I was
eating death and then I just let loose
and they went [__] bananas I said
[__] it I'll just take the 200 for the
night I don't give a [__] I walked off
she didn't talk to me
the next night I came in the husband was
there I pulled the Messiah she didn't
[__] know she goes ah I explained to
her last night what happened I'm sorry
Danny that was his name I'm sorry I go
up there and right there it was one of
those clubs where right here is the
stage and people actually take their
drinks and they're looking at me like
this
and 20 minutes into my [__] show I'm
looking at this couple and I'm looking
at her and she's [__] up John Rogan
she's [__] up and I'm like oh Jesus
Christ and finally I keep checking out
like every eight minutes and she's
getting deeper and deeper she's closing
one eye once they close the one eye
they're [__] up and finally I saw go
like this
and she covers her dog no no no no no
the puke starts shooting not every box
like a [__] what's that thing the
kid's playing like a like a sprinkler
but just awkward chunks and then she
just let it all out and she sat there
for five minutes puking all over herself
bro nobody paid everybody got up like
somebody was shooting he thought
terrorists were shooting in the club
everybody got up and started running for
the [__] door they had to stop people
she had a puddle of barf around like the
boyfriend left her there the boyfriend
just got up and walked out there
you didn't see me with me give me back
my credit card I never went back there
again when somebody pukes on stage I
can't I can't hang out with you no more
it's amazing like the bad advice they
give you early on in your stand-up
career I want to shoot them all on the
[__] hat they would always tell you
you can't make it if you're dirty like
they tell you can't make it I mean I I
can't remember how many times I heard
what is a [__] pipe holy [__]
somebody gave me that in Cleveland
that's the Savage stuff we only let him
out for special occasions he's amazing
oh my god do the people at home see this
thing oh that thing is [__]
tremendous oh this is who did this work
you know somebody in Cleveland there's a
whole uh industry like a whole art form
now the glass pipe art form industry I
mean it's there's an amazing artists
that are just throwing glass I got
another one at the house and the kid
gave me that I don't even want to smoke
on it it's so beautiful incredible I
need a picture that's the Sabbath that's
the original right there he's missing
the tooth he don't give a [__]
what kind of advice do they give you for
someone puking on you when you're on
stage they didn't say nothing they can't
they can't give you advice for that
there was no advice I walked off the
stage and knew I wasn't going to be ever
there ever again you understand me
that's what I knew for sure
look at me John
there's some places you [__] go and
you know you're never going to go back
to they would just tell you like they
would give you advice like when you're
young you're starting out like say if
you're a young guy and you're afraid let
me know the people everybody that you
look at today and go what's I want to
say their names they never made it that
they never made the one guy that did
make it that had already made it at the
time who gave me the opposite advice was
Lenny Clark it was funny because his
brother Mike was a booking agent who's a
great guy Mike Clark that guy paid my
rent [__] many many many many times
with his gigs because he was one of the
guys that he had a lot of satellite
rooms he had giggles and Saugus on Route
One
and um he had a few uh outside rooms and
he would book his brother Lenny and
Lenny was on HBO he had done Rodney
Dangerfield special Lenny was a big
comic he'd done a bunch of movies like
Lenny was big and this is before Lenny's
sitcom and when he had that sitcom
and uh I opened up for Lenny's at Jay's
in Pittsfield Massachusetts it was in
Western Massachusetts it was way out
there like two and a half three hours
away from Boston and uh people loved it
there because it was a real stage and
they had real comedy there like they had
Lenny Clark when Lenny Clark was big and
I went up and I opened up for land he
was the second paid gig I ever got in my
life
and I got off stage and Mike Clark said
body you're [__] funny but I can't
book you you're too dirty and he goes
that bit you do about Madonna you can't
do that it's like it's funny but I know
you gotta clean it up you gotta clean it
up and uh so Lenny comes off stage right
after his brother gives me advice Lenny
comes out said he goes can you a [__]
hilarious
he goes don't change
laughing my balls off and he goes Lenny
I just told him to stop doing that bit
he goes oh yeah yeah yeah you should
probably stop doing it it's gonna be
hard to get work but [__] kid you're
funny and uh it was like a good advice
and bad advice and I listened to Lenny I
was like you know his brother's a great
guy and everything like that but Lenny
is Lenny Clark so they have Lenny Clark
tell you you're funny I was like oh wow
that was huge for me but his brother's
giving me bad advice he's like but he
wanted me to work you know it's like but
that was the thing back then it was in
1989 or 1988. back then you couldn't
work if you were dirty like there was no
work everybody wanted to get on The
Tonight Show no there was a few HBO
specials that had been given out like to
Kennison and a few other people but
you want to be somebody to get those if
you wanted to be dirty you got to be
somebody already so what it was was a
lot of these guys who were you know
quote unquote dirty they would have
clean sets that they would do on The
Tonight Show or Letterman or whatever
and then they would have a few dirty
bits that they would reserve for a
nightclub and they would close with
those bits so if they ever did an HBO
special that's when they would do those
I knew I had to be dirty three years in
like I was just lying to myself
people would come up to me with that
[__] [__] and I gave this New
York try I tried it I tried it but it
just didn't work out for me I don't I'm
not gonna ask you to do a joke but like
what was a clean premise for you I
really know a clean premise for you to
be honest that's old weed that was it
all right a clean premise in those days
was
a clean premise hold on hold on a clean
premise in those days was a Godzilla
look at this thing you guys are Advanced
here what would Godzilla do
if he came back into the Hudson you know
it was terrible it was terrible it was
brutally terrible
I had a thing about uh a ship going into
the Hudson I had a thing about speakers
you could put them back in the windows
because bows some electric it was just a
hobby it was a [__] Horror Show
you know I can't imagine you making
electronic jokes Joey used to try to be
clean in the early days when I first saw
him it was a nightmare Joey was um
trying to deal with um agents and
managers when you first moved to LA oh
my God we first became friends yeah you
were you were dealing with all of us and
one day you go you know what it really
doesn't matter I never had that nowhere
else I went to karate since I was a kid
nobody's let me do these things nobody's
laughed at you well you know what the
difference is one of the big ones is in
karate you don't want anybody hitting
you like people hit each other you hurt
each other like there was a camaraderie
that we had in in martial arts but it
was always still a little weird because
you would Spar when he'd Spar you'd hurt
each other and the Jiu Jitsu you Spar I
mean you could be real good friends you
could go full blast and the like the
better you get actually the safer it is
to go full blast because like you I know
that you know there's certain guys
they'll get you in something you can tap
and they have full control you're not
going to get hurt it's almost like the
guys who aren't as good or more
dangerous because they're going to try
to yank on something and they could wind
up injuring you so like when when you
get like guys who you become like real
competitive with and you get that
camaraderie it's actually better and
you're super super competitive with each
other but always super supportive and
really friendly because you can be like
you want a guy to like you you want to
like each other and you can still go
full blast like I have real good friends
tap me you know and it doesn't it's not
a bad thing at all it's not a giggle I
love it it is what it is you know like
Eddie's tapped me every time we've
rolled I mean I maybe one or two times
I've ever rolled with them and just
stalemated them like kept them off me
like being just 100 defensive most of
the time he catches me two or three
times every time we roll but we're best
friends you know a million guys from
that gym it's the same story like Denny
Denny's caught me before and you know he
just was the greatest game ever he just
won yeah he's had a lot of neck problems
he's had some neck problems I want to
update we worked on the Breath of Fire
he's a bad [__] you're broken
the Breath of Fire [__] I don't
know what that is well we'll do that
tomorrow Joe Rogan I love you I love you
too brother 11 o'clock it's fun to do
this man yeah yeah no thank you for
coming it was a pleasure the candle
burned down once the candle burns out
it's time to go
that sounded like you threw a [__]
M80 into a bucket of water
[Music]